a manifestaciones y reclamos resonaron
al unísono en el día internacional de
los trabajadores
decenas de miles de personas se
manifestaron en las calles francesas
este primero de mayo en un contexto
preelectoral de cara a las
parlamentarias tras la elección de
manuel macrón el líder izquierdista
francés jean-luc mélenchon aseguró que
una victoria en las parlamentarias es
posible e insistió sobre lo que fue uno
de sus caballos de batalla en las
presidenciales la edad de jubilación
pues ahora se trata de
ese es el gran avance que nos está
propulsando con ustedes que cuando se
reúnen para el primero de mayo son los
herederos los fieles herederos de los
que hable mente y en medio de tantas
dificultades llevaron a cuestas la
mejora del avión por la libertad para
escoger a sí mismo a través de un tiempo
de contrato que decreció
las manifestaciones en parís terminaron
en choques con la policía
[Aplausos]
e italia los sindicatos se reunieron
cientos de personas en asís para hacer
un llamado a trabajar por la paz en las
calles de grecia a unas diez mil
personas se manifestaron en contra de
los altos precios de la energía y
exigieron mejores salarios y condiciones
laborales
en alemania cientos protestaron durante
un mitin del canciller olaf scholz
mientras que en turquía decenas de
manifestantes fueron detenidos por
marchar en zonas no autorizadas según
las autoridades
russia la televisión estatal difundió
imágenes de un mitin del partido
comunista en moscú el líder de esa tolda
política no escatimó en críticas a
occidente
[Música]
por primera vez los anglosajones
declararon la guerra a nuestro país se
llama guerra híbrida pero ya está
ardiendo en todos los frentes desde las
finanzas hasta ucrania
y en corea del sur la confederación
coreana de sindicatos se reunió a miles
en seúl quienes reclamaron empleos de
alta calidad sin amenazas de despidos
los asistentes marcharon hasta la
oficina del equipo de transición del
presidente electo de esa nación asiática